there's two ways I think we can deal
with future pandemics one is what we did
previously which is we did work to try
to bring viruses from the wild into Labs
play with them to see if they have
Pandemic potential try to develop
vaccines early and then try to deal with
the pandemics as they come up the idea
is to prevent the pandemic and if they
happen be prepared to deal with them
it's quite likely or certainly possible
at least that this pandemic may have
been caused by that very research if
there's a lab leak it's because somebody
brought it back virus that's very close
to sarskov 2 into a lab played with it
gave it the capacity to infect humans
and it leaked accidentally I'm not
saying that's happened for sure but it's
certainly a live hypothesis and if
that's true that strategy of dealing
with pandemics will have that forever
with us if we keep that
foreign